dude I wouldn't even perform these
records They didn't even tour it it was
so painful after because it didn't work
we broke up it was the biggest
heartbreak of my life and I
honestly felt like I was gonna die
Jennifer Lopez always keeping it
this time about her 2004 breakup from
now hubby Ben Affleck it was my first
kind of heartbreak it was my first like
adult heartbreak and in a new interview
with apple music's Zane Lowe Jen says
that heartbreak took a toll on her music
dude I wouldn't even perform these
records last week the singer announced
she's releasing a new album this is me
now in 2023
[Music]
this is me then
[Music]
[Music]
this is me now yeah it's a follow-up to
her 2002 album this is me then which she
released while she and Ben were in a
relationship the first time around you
know the album with this classic Ben
Jen's co-star in the music video
[Music]
that album this is me then really
captured a moment in time where I fell
in love with the love of my life me
tweaking the lyrics with him like every
single song that we wrote there me
riding dear Ben
[Music]
a manifestation of my dreams
it was such a special
moment in time to have captured are you
guys going to get used to seeing us
again
but fast forward two years and benefit
ended their engagement in 2004 and Jen
says it was too painful for her to play
music from that record it was the
biggest heartbreak of my life and I
honestly felt like I was gonna die and
it sent me on a spiral for the next 18
years where
I just was you know
couldn't get it right it's funny because
when me and Ben got back together he
said to me he was like you never
performed the songs like you never did
I'm glad
you never did this and I was like you're
right I said it was painful it was like
it was a part of me then that I had to
put away to kind of move on and survive
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak like you know just one of
those breakups that really you know it
was like
a tough one for me for whatever reason
but get this Ben's a big fan he loves
that album
he loves that music
he knows all of the words you know what
I mean and he's my biggest fan which is
awesome and uh and supporter what can I
tell you we're just having a good time
and since the two rekindled their
romance in 2021 and tied the knot a year
later JLo says new music naturally came
next and when he came back into my life
again the same thing happened
where I felt so inspired
and so
overtaken with emotion that is just
pouring out of me I think what I with
the message of the album is very much if
you were wondering
if you have like me at times lost hope
almost given up don't
because true love does exist we're super
happy and benefit 2.0 they're in it for
the long haul there's no questions and
there is no
kind of like well let's see how this
goes like nope
it's me and you
that's it
all the way
till the end that's it it's gonna be us
[Music]